RIOTERS WERE HUGGING AND KISSING
POLICE ON THAT DAY.
SOME REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS ARE
FOLLOWING TRUMP'S EXAMPLE,
TRYING ON REWRITE WHAT HAPPENED
ON JANUARY 6th.
FOR INSTANCE, BY CALLING THE
ATTACKERS, QUOTE, PEACEFUL
PATRIOTS.
465 ARRESTS SUGGEST OTHERWISE.
THEY'VE CLAIMED THE ATTACKERS
WEREN'T ARMED.
FOR THE RECORD, 40 SUSPECTS HAVE
BEEN CHARGED WITH ENTERING THE
CAPITOL WITH A DANGEROUS OR
DEADLY WEAPON.
ONE REPUBLICAN SAID IT WAS AKIN
TO A NORMAL CAPITOL TOUR.
WELL, TELL THAT TO THE 140
POLICE OFFICERS WHO WERE
ASSAULTED AND TELL THAT TO THE
FAMILY OF FALLEN OFFICER BRIAN
SICKNICK, OR THE FAMILIES OF THE
TWO OFFICE HERE'S DIED BY
SUICIDE DAYS LATER.
>>> AND TELL THAT TO THE 17
OFFICERS STILL UNABLE TO RETURN
TO WORK BECAUSE OF INJURIES THEY
SUSTAINED WHILE BEATING BACK THE
INSURRECTION.
IT WAS A FIGHT SO BAD SOME
DIDN'T THINK THEY WOULD MAKE IT
HOME TO THEIR FAMILIES.
>> I DIDN'T THINK I WOULD BE
ABLE TO SEE THEM.
I WENT TO MY SON'S VAN AND GAVE
HIM A HUG.
HE WAS ASLEEP STILL.
I GAVE HIM A BIG KISS AND I JUST
STARTED CRYING.
IT'S LIKE FIVE, TEN MINUTES HUG
AT LEAST.
I JUST CRIED.
I KEPT TELLING HIM, HE WOULD BE
OKAY AND I KNOW I HAVE TO GO
BACK TO WORK.
>> SO BEFORE TRUMP TRIES TO GAS
LIGHT THE NATION AGAIN TONIGHT,
LET'S SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED ON THAT DARK
DAY NEARLY FIVE MONTHS AGO
TOMORROW.
THE TWO CAPITOL POLICE OFFICERS
WHO WERE THERE.
I'M JOINED BY THE SERGEANT YOU
JUST HEARD FROM, SERGEANT
GONELL, ALSO WITH ME, CAPITOL
POLICE OFFICER HARRY DUNN.
THEY ARE HERE SPEAKING FOR
THEMSELVES AND NOT THEIR
DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR COMING HERE.
WE SHOULD KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR 13 YEARS.
BUT THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
YOU'VE SEEN EACH OTHER IN PERSON
SINCE THE INSURRECTION.
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
>> WHAT IS IT LIKE TO BE
REUNITED IN A SENSE, AFTER GOING
THROUGH WHAT YOU BOTH WENT
THROUGH?
>> FOR ME, IT IS THE FIRST
PERSON THAT I'VE SEEN FROM THE
DEPARTMENT SINCE I LEFT ON THE
20th.
VERY HAPPY TO SEE HIM.
HE'S DOING WELL.
I'M DOING A LOT BETTER NOW.
IT'S GREAT.
GOOD TO SEE HIM.
>> WHEN I FIRST SAW HIM, I GAVE
HIM A BIG OLD HUG.
WE TALKED ON THE PHONE BUT IT
WAS JUST GOOD TO SEE HIM.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE HIM, YOU CAN.
I'M GLAD HE'S GOOD.
>> YEAH.
YOU WALKED IN.
GAVE HIM A HUGE BEAR HUG.
AND YOU SAT IN ON A PREVIOUS
INTERVIEW I WATCHED, OFFICER
DUNN, THAT YOU FIND SOLACE
TALKING TO OTHER OFFICERS
BECAUSE SO FEW CAN RELATE TO
WHAT THEY EXPERIENCED THAT DAY,
JANUARY 6th.
>> I THINK THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT
EVEN MORE SPECIAL.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE ONLY KNOW WHAT
IT IS LIKE.
ALL THE PEOPLE IN THE WORLD AND
ONLY A FEW PEOPLE THAT KNOW HOW
YOU'RE FEELING.
EVEN THEN, IT IS NOT EVEN
COMPLETELY THE SAME.
EVERYBODY DEALT WITH IT
DIFFERENTLY.
THEY DEAL WITH THEIR EMOTIONS
SOME PEOPLE DON'T EVEN WANT TO
TALK ABOUT IT AND THAT'S HOW
THEY DEAL WITH IT.
IT JUST MAKES ME HAPPY.
>> AND YOU'RE PART OF WHAT
INSPIRED HIM TO REACH OUT.
YOU WERE NOT SEEKING THE
LIMELIGHT.
>> I WAS NOT SEEKING IT EITHER.
>> AND YOU WEREN'T SEEKING IT
EITHER.
>> SEEKING THE TRUTH.
>> LAST WEEK WHEN I SAT IN MY
BED JUST EATING AND I SEE
OFFICER SICKNICK'S FAMILY,
OFFICER FANONE NEXT TO THEM.
I SEE THEM PLEADING TO THESE
SENATORS, GOING TO THEIR
OFFICES, SUPPORT THIS.
WE DESERVE THIS.
IT IS THE LEAST YOU CAN DO.
FOR THEM TO NOT LISTEN, TO NOT
COME THROUGH WITH THAT.
WE GAVE THEM THE TIME TO GO TO
SAFETY AND THEY ARE NOT
APPRECIATING THAT.
WE PUT OUT OUR LIVES.
WHILE THEY WERE RUNNING, WE HELD
THE LINE.
AND WE SACRIFICED SO MUCH FOR
THEM TO NOT ONLY PUT EVERYTHING
ON THE LINE BUT THEY'RE NOT
FULFILLING THEIR OATH OF OFFICE,
TO PUT THE COUNTRY BEFORE THE
PARTY.
>> AND FOR ME TO CONTINUE WITH
THESE LIES, IT IS UNCALLED FOR.
IT IS A BETRAYAL TO THE
OFFICERS.
AND THAT'S ONE THING THAT
COMPELLED ME TO COME FORWARD.
I WASN'T GOING TO COME OUT AND
STEP UP AND SPEAK ABOUT THIS
PUBLICLY.
THAT DAY I SAW MY FAMILY
LITERALLY BEGGING THEM TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED.
TALK ABOUT CANCEL CULTURE.
YOU DON'T EVEN WANT TO RECORD
THIS IN HISTORY BUT YOU COMPLAIN
ABOUT ALL THE THINGS.
IT IS UNCALLED FOR.
>> AND YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THOSE REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED
AGAINST THE JANUARY 6th
COMMISSION.
YOU WERE THERE ON CAPITOL HILL,
MEETING WITH THESE LAWMAKERS.
YOU WERE THERE WITH BRIAN
SICKNICK'S MOTHER, WITH HIS
PARTNER.
AND THEN AS WE KNOW, THOSE
LAWMAKERS STRUCK IT DOWN.
THEY VOTED AGAINST IT.
I WANT TO LISTEN AND GET YOUR
REACTION ON THE OTHER TONED WHAT
THEY SAID TO MY COLLEAGUE JAKE
TAPPER.
>> IF THEY HAD A CHILD THAT WAS
HURT, WAS KILLED ON A DAY LIKE
THAT, THEY WOULD THINK VERY
DIFFERENTLY.
WHAT IF THEY WERE HURT?
SOMEBODY COULD HAVE BEEN KILLED.
ONE OF THE CONGRESSMEN, ONE OF
THE SENATORS.
BUT APPARENTLY, THEY JUST THINK,
WELL, WE'RE SAFE BECAUSE OF THE
MEN IN BLUE.
>> I THINK IT IS ALL TALK AND NO
ACTION.
CLEARLY THEY'RE NOT BACK IN THE
BLUE.
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE TO ME THAT
THEY COULD DO NOTHING ABOUT
THIS.
SO OFFICER DONE, YOU HEARD WHAT
THEY HAD TO SAY.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION?
IS IT THE SAME AS THEIRS, THAT
THE WHOLE BACKING THE BLUE TALK
WAS JUST TALK, NO ACTION?
>> SO THEY'RE SUCH STRONG WOMEN.
IT TOOK SO MUCH COURAGE AND
STRENGTH FOR THEM TO COME DOWN.
AND LOBBY FOR JUSTICE.
AND HONESTLY, I BELIEVE THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
ACCOUNTABILITY.
JUSTICE.
WE WEREN'T JUST BLUE.
WE WEREN'T JUST POLICE OFFICERS
THERE.
WE WERE VICTIMS OF AN ATTACK AND
WE DESERVE JUSTICE.
WE DESERVE TO KNOW EVERYBODY
INVOLVED.
WE WANT THEM HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
EVERYBODY WHO HAD ANY PART IN
IT.
NOT JUST THE PEOPLE WHO CARRIED
OUT THE ACTIONS BUT THOSE WHO
INCITED IT.
THEY NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
AND US POLICE OFFICERS, THE
BLUE, WE DESERVE THAT.
JUST LIKE ANY OTHER VICTIM IN
THIS COUNTRY.
SO TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, I
CAN'T SAY WITH A CLEAR
CONSCIENCE THAT THEY DON'T
SUPPORT BLUE.
I CAN'T SAY THAT.
I BELIEVE THEY'RE GETTING THEIR
JUDGMENT CLOUDED WITH POLITICS.
AND IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
POLITICS.
IT HAS EVERYTHING TO DO WITH
WHAT IS RIGHT AND WHAT IS WRONG.
AND YOUR CONSCIENCE.
LIZ CHENEY WHO IS A
CONSERVATIVE, I BELIEVE SHE'S
VOTED WITH TRUMP 90 PLUS PERCENT
OF THE TIME.
SHE IS OUSTED FOR NOT LYING.
I JUST FEEL LIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE
NEED TO FOLLOW THEIR CONSCIENCE
AND GET OUT OF -- THEY'RE IN
THEIR OWN WAY.
TELL THE TRUTH.
I DON'T KNOW HOW ANYBODY CAN
LIVE WITH THEMSELVES BEING
DISHONEST.
YOU CAN APOLOGIZE TO PEOPLE.
YOU CAN APOLOGIZE TO EVERYBODY
IN THIS WORLD.
YOU APOLOGIZE TO YOURSELF,
KNOWING THAT YOU'RE FULL OF
CRAP?
HOW DO YOU LIVE WITH YOURSELF?
>> AND LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
TRUTH.
LET'S TALK ABOUT MORE ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED THAT DAY.
WE HAVE VIDEO OF YOU.
YOU WERE RIGHT IN THE THICK OF
IT.
IN THE VERY FRONT.
YOU TOLD ME RIGHT AFTER 1:00.
I BELIEVE WE HAVE VIDEO OF YOU
HERE.
THIS WAS ONE OF THE OFFICERS.
YOU WERE FEET AWAY.
WHAT WAS GOING ON WHEN YOU SAW
THIS?
>> GUT WRENCHING.
I'M RIGHT NEXT TOM YOUNG LADY ON
THE LEFT SIDE.
AND THERE WAS NOTHING I COULD DO
TO HELP THEM.
I HEAR HIM SCREAM.
EVERY TIME I HEAR HIM SCREAM, IT
IS GUT WRENCHING.
IT BAFFLES ME THAT PEOPLE ARE
CALLING THIS A TOUR.
IT BOTHERS ME.
THAT'S AN INSULT.
THIS IS NOT A TOUR.
THIS IS NOT A CONCERT.
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE PRETENDING
THAT ANYBODY CAME INTO THE
CAPITOL FOR THE FOURTH OF JULY
CONCERT OR MEMORIAL DAY, AND
THEN DID WHATEVER THEY DID AND
WENT HOME LIKE NOTHING HAPPENED.
WE OFFICERS, WE WERE LIVING
THIS.
WHEN WE GET PHONE CALLS FROM THE
FBI, HEY, DO YOU RECOGNIZE THIS
OFFICER?
HE GOT ASSAULTED BY THIS
INDIVIDUAL.
DO YOU SEE YOURSELF, DO YOU
REMEMBER WHEN YOU WERE STRUCK?
WATCHING THE VIDEO?
WATCHING THE PICTURES?
WE ARE STILL LIVING IT.
MEANWHILE FOR SOME OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS CALLING THIS A
FANTASY, LIKE IT NEVER HAPPENED.
WE GAVE THEM THE TIME FOR THEM
TO ESCAPE.
WE GAVE THEM THE TIME TO GO TO
SAFETY.
THINKING WHEN THEY DID COME
BACK, AND THEY DID COME BACK